this is in Florida and a seven-year-old
was surfing they put a GoPro on his
surfboard his dad and him go surfing all
the time and there's a shark that
actually knocked him off his boards but
it's hard to see now and it's a small
shark but it's pretty cool
oh [ __ ] you see it there yeah just do
you see him go you hit it I think
there's some slo-moes here yeah he got
it he hit im hit the shark and shouts
take a black tip it's a block dip and
you'll see it again here and oh my
Sharkies boom yeah that's just a little
thing okay shark was just afraid he's
probably swimming and then the surfboard
came in just like that the santa cruz
guys out surfing early-morning
santa cruz he comes back and he's like a
great white just put me in its mouth
what everybody goes why he goes a great
white just swallowed me and spit me back
out they go [ __ ] under his board
where his waist is they see the top they
see where is wetsuit is and there are
bite marks at his wetsuit
where his hip is his back is and under
the board there are teeth stuck in the
[ __ ] surfboard the shark came up out
of the water and went room and went oh
god you're wood and rubber and spit him
back out in the morning for home I enjoy
that wonder how big it was since he went
all the way into the shark's mouth in
the show you got slip back out how about
that Jesus days then there
[Laughter]
I won't interrupt you I don't have any
you know I didn't think about that story
no I not have any documented proof but
it was told me by heck girl I went in
for school in 1991 her name is Minnie
and now I think about she's full of [ __ ]
I think about it that story is thirty
years old
absolutely outbreak there is another
story I did I've been telling a story
forever
I've been realize and I realize that
maybe it didn't happen that never
happens why podcast is good let me just
leave that I'd let you go for a while I
was a guy guys I saw a chart did grab a
guy on a board and throw him do you keep
doing it now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]